2,000 more 3,000 how many more
Palestinians would make you happy if
they die hey guys here's one of the
Hamas caucus members doing the usual
busy work for the bad people question
your colleague Richie Torres has said
calling for a ceasefire is a dangerous
double standard that the US wouldn't
hold themselves to so my question is is
if this attack happened in America would
you be calling for a ceasefire as
well vengeance is not a foreign policy
Doctrine uh we are here to save lives
yes or a no anyone
else I do have another question why
don't you want Israelis to go after the
terrorists that burned tortured killed
their babies and children and still have
them hostage why don't you want the
Israelis to go after the terrorist that
did that how many more killings is
enough for you is it a th000 more 2,000
more 3,000 how many more Palestinians
would make you Happ happy if they die do
you you will you be fine if all of the
people of GAA were gone would that make
you happy would that be the thing that
makes you proud and maybe that's the
question you should ask Richie is he
okay how many more Palestinian lives is
he comfortable because I'm not
comfortable with
anymore any other
questions I guess my last question would
be what do you say to the Israeli people
that feel like you're telling them to do
nothing when their children are being
held hostage by
terrorists